a group of Smash ultimate players have
been playing online tournaments under
the shared Alias Phantom thieves that's
right five players One account zero
concern for messing up the bracket I
guess but come on like this has to be
one of the weirder cheating scandals of
2023 like even at this early stage right
[Music]
hey guys before we get into the video I
just wanted to remind you that if you
enjoy the work we do here it really does
help if you like the video subscribe to
the channel and ring the notification
Bell I feel like we've been doing some
really cool reporting in this series
recently and you wouldn't want to miss
out when we drop a new report so if you
feel like supporting the channel those
are great ways to do it let's get back
to the video okay so get this I wake up
roll out of bed slurp down a coffee and
when I sit down at my PC I'm confronted
by this
what
[Music]
huh
no way this guy has
yeah so that was hungrybox witnessing a
team up attack by these so-called
Phantom thieves who we would later learn
are a group of five players who are
playing smash ultimate tournaments under
this shared Phantom thieves Alias who
exactly are the Phantom thieves though
at the time only the players themselves
knew and hbox continued to piece the
story together on Twitter which we'll
talk about in a moment but before we go
any further yeah you can't just share an
account and swap off during a tournament
that's against the rules checking out
their start.gg page and their Twitter
feed you can see that they've been
playing in a lot of online tournaments
and also that they've been issuing
ominous messages to people that they are
likely to play in the bracket now one of
the tournaments of the Phantom thieves
participated in was coinbox 47 along
with some of the earlier iterations of
this tournament so all in all the
Phantom thieves appear to have been
entering tournaments for just over a
month a tweet by acid seems to show the
confirmation of the situation he played
Phantom thieves in both winners and
losers but showed Joker and Noir
profiles in his recently played with
screen meaning that Phantom thieves did
use different players against him so why
are they using these weird names well
it's from Persona 5. now when you're
actually playing Persona 5 the plot of
the game is actually pretty cool and my
co-worker Danielle Rosen got me into the
series earlier in the pandemic and it's
been pretty cool to play through the
three most recent games they have
awesome stories would highly recommend
now when a bunch of people decide to do
their own live-action role play version
of Persona 5 in chats with their
competitors and moderators well that's
just a lot less intentionally
entertaining though I will say this one
is absolutely hilarious Justice shall
show who is in the right from this very
test Mr future I hope you are ready for
date fate I
I one minute please my my it seems like
Shadow kirosh has fixed their connection
I might need Oracle to do a scouting
report on this bro talk normally thou
shalma talk in just gestures that reveal
thy true self also my co-worker Danielle
said that that first part where they
mess up was definitely ryuji texting and
I 100 agree for real anyways that's
enough about Persona so I read the note
about the story and stupid me I figured
there must be some kind of pattern to
their targets so this is based partially
on the fact that it happens in the video
game for reasons I'm not going to talk
about right now but also because well
they went to the trouble of doing it of
calling out these players like what was
the point of that so again I the utter
fool decided to try and look to see if
there were some kind of connections or
something between these targets like
what could their motivations be and yeah
as far as I could tell they didn't have
one the Phantom thieves just called out
people that they they thought would be
in their path in the bracket so instead
of taking Hearts they just took away
people's opportunity to have a fair
competitive bracket and so my big weird
cork board with newspaper clippings push
pins and string it was all a huge waste
of time that I could have used to work
on my main writing assignment right now
because by the time I logged on to do
some casual night work they had already
admitted to it in his twit longer he
accepted responsibility for some of the
accounts activity and said that they
hadn't claimed any money they wouldn't
claim any money and that if someone was
upset and lost out on money he's willing
to make it right later in one of the
replies he said that he didn't start the
group but was invited to it and used the
name Noir he also pointed to desk
another smash player as another member
of the group now this twit logger
doesn't 100 prove that they were in
control of the start.gg account and
there was a burst of Twitter activity on
the Phantom thieves account on Tuesday
night we don't know for sure who else
exactly exactly was involved yet but
obviously doing something like this is
against the rules of
basically every tournament is this a
massive violation deserving of prison
sentences and Exile from Smash Island I
guess no obviously not they give back to
15 bucks and they apologize and
everybody admits their involvement I
think they should get a slap on the
wrist because yes it did affect the
competitive Integrity of these
tournaments but they are smaller online
tournaments they're willing to make it
right and if they promise not to do it
again then I think we can all learn a
valuable lesson here but I'm also not
going to pretend that it was very funny
either like for real for real if there
had been some kind of logic to the
Target some desired goal anything you
know that would be cooler than this plus
let's not forget like one of the reasons
that we have evidence about multiple
people on the Phantom thieves account is
that acid played them in both winners
and losers if that hadn't happened and
they hadn't swapped who was playing then
we wouldn't have that screenshot so yeah
they did try to use the fact that they
had multiple players to their advantage
the point I've seen a lot of people make
is that people are taking online too
seriously and I think there is some
truth to that let's be real there isn't
an admin standing in every living room
where every switch is located or
whatever making sure that only one
person is playing it so there are plenty
of opportunities for things to be well
not quite completely above board but
that doesn't mean that we should be okay
with people going out of their way to
disrupt the tournaments either like
that's that doesn't follow no one's
pretending these online weeklies are are
a major but they have enough problems
without people actively causing more of
them and if this was your own tournament
in your own apartment with your own
friends
do whatever you want I mean dress up as
a phantom thieves if you want I don't
care it's not affecting other people but
this did given that the states don't
seem that high I can't help but think
that it's probably just a matter of time
until the co-conspirators come forward
and admit their involvement in the
situation until that happens though I'm
feeling a little hungry I'm gonna go get
some pancakes
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and Tech talk